avant avant d'appeler la bile à enora je
vais vous poser la question et chez vous
vous allez essayer de trouver également
enora va-t-elle tenir plus longtemps ou
moins longtemps que nabila sur une base
de pause elle sa fin vous avez cinq
secondes vous jouez aussi la villa et
laura a dit moi j'ai vu arriver des
questions alors c'est quoi la question
allez on accueille enora et l'habitat
[Applaudissements]
la question la question était et laura
va-t-il va-t-elle tenir puisqu'il n'aura
est un garçon et nora va tenir plus
longtemps ou moins longtemps que nabila
sur une barre de pole dance alors vous
ne devez pas faire de ses biens c'est
comme un peu collante âge nous accrocher
à la barre d'accord les flip
voilà les pattes bien sûr or ce match
c'est donc une poule des pathologies
maladies dont vous accrocher sur la
barre voilà bien sûr les pieds bien sûr
en l'air et c'est celle qui restera le
plus longtemps alors pour savoir qui va
commencer
bien sûr on va procéder aux chiffons me
pierre feuille ciseaux venez là
attention mains derrière le dos pierre
feuille ciseaux je rappelle il je
rappelle pour ceux qui nous regardent le
puits ne compte pas maintenant voilà
c'est pierre feuille ciseaux dans le
chiffon mais attention chez fo mines est
pareil lapierre non j'ai beau me alors
je vais vous donner j'ai ordonné une
technique sur le chiffon
sachez le c'est bien de faire deux fois
le même truc parce que souvent la
personne d'en face
[Rires]
alors et dans l'axé lui donc allez
commencer et nos alesi et nos grands
pères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette koh-lanta
deux semaines elle allait bien
ouais
attention attention draka
la tension narrative cela doit battre 40
secondes
nabila la barre n'est pas fixe c'est
parti on n'est pas à la tentation
c'est beau ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
la ville allait à la dure et 16 secondes
ces choses seront et dieu sait que sept
secondes
parfois c'est très très long je sais ce
que c'est allez nabil alors à voir avec
mercialys
merci bonjour merci à l'estomac
m